all I have to say is I hope there is
such a thing as clean coal and the
reason I say that and of course that
means that we can burn coal and
completely capture the co2 and then
sequester it and it's certainly not an
easy thing to do but what I keep
reminding people is a coal is the
world's most abundant energy resources
now you can argue whether it's as
abundant as solar or wind but certainly
in terms of conventional resources and
what people forget is that coal employs
literally tens of thousands of people
around the world not only in our own
country but in places like India and
China it is cheap and so it's very
difficult for emerging market countries
that are trying to electrify - to grow
their economies economically it's very
difficult for them to simply say well
we're going to stop using coal because
of concerns about climate change because
not only will they throw thousands of
people out of work but they will not
then and probably in the near term have
a readily available alternative to
replace the coal generated electricity
that's leading to these explosive levels
of economic growth so I hope that we put
a lot of research and development there
essentially three major ways that we
think about right now to do it
potentially have clean coal one involves
taking the co2 out before combustion and
to capturing it after combustion but I
would like to see us cooperate with the
other big coal users in Indonesia and
China India and may be jointly embarked
on and some more research and
development projects using these three
technologies and not see it as a
commercial gain of one country's going
to learn how to do it not other but
butts and of the rubric of the global
good that we all do it together and then
to share the benefits accordingly